what started with a virus so small your
eyes couldn't see it this is about
providing a future for humanity the
commission has decided to find google
4.34 billion euros
we are innovating here and we hope that
you like it
welcome to europe calling a series of
podcasts brought to you by the european
commission
looking at the politics and policies of
the union today
me paul anderson and me steven jones in
our two previous episodes we've focused
on the health and economic afterburn of
covid
as well as the strategic plan to boost
industry in europe
and improve its global competitiveness
today we are focusing on the vast
jobs and social welfare dimension how to
use this terrible pandemic to rethink
the workplace jobs market
and social welfare provisions how to
address youth unemployment
which at more than 30 percent in some
mediterranean countries
is nothing short of chronic for this
episode i've been to one of those
countries paul
italy and the island of sardinia
exploring the torn
employment and social fabric of what
many outsiders see simply as a
sun-drenched holiday paradise
we'll hear from you there shortly
stephen but steering us through all
these issues on the wider eu level
is our key guest today nikola schmidt
european commissioner for jobs and
social rights
from luxembourg his portfolio
encompasses many policy sectors that are
fundamental to the eu's mission
and vision freedom of movement mutual
recognition of qualifications
skills and workplace improvement and
cushioning the more detrimental effects
of globalization
like job loss among them a very warm
welcome commissioner schmidt from me and
stephen
and to you our listeners it's a great
pleasure to be uh to be here and to be
with you
and uh hopefully to be able to answer
your questions
we hope so too commissioner we hope so
too and with a critical ear
and some questions of his own we welcome
to the studio also panayotis chassis
mikhail a board member of the european
youth
forum thank you very much for the
invitation and happy to be here
we're also going to be looking at the
ongoing eu-wide debate on the future of
europe
but first to the main issue at hand the
condition of europe's
social and employment safety net and the
man in charge of the portfolio
commissioner nicolas schmidt
commissioner schmidt is often said that
kovid represents an opportunity to
rethink the world of work
to embrace workplace and social
innovations
what changes do you foresee after this
pandemic
and of the pathways to realizing that
well i think
that the kovit 19 has increased the
awareness
that health and safety at the workplace
is of utmost
importance if you are not able to
protect
workers against all kinds of threats
coming from
illnesses like covet 19 or other
dangerous substances you put at risk
finally not only the life of workers but
in a way our values
what work represents now the commission
has come out
with a new strategic framework on health
and safety
and uh certainly this framework also
absolutely takes into account
the new dangers the new risks like the
pandemic but also
mental health risks which develop
very fast this sounds like a compelling
exercise in future proofing or at least
future improving
but it's clear people's minds are on the
now and getting back to normal
as soon as possible for many people they
want
business as usual i think a return to
normal or some kind of new normal in my
view
absolutely impossible because it's not
just about the covet 19
it's about an enormous huge
change in our in our society in our
economies due to
technological change digitalization
our obligation to respond to climate
change
so talking about the new normal would
say that
finally we haven't learned the lessons
okay
let's look wider now the power dynamics
driving the change that you speak of
the eu has a secondary role to member
states
in social welfare provision and in the
jobs market
yet it's an area where the expectations
of citizens
in the eu's capacity to deliver change
are particularly high
in fact just before the porto social
summit in may
around half of member states staked out
their sovereign territory reminding you
that social policy is their prerogative
not yours
so how do you reconcile that imbalance
in power and capacity to act on a
european level
it's a shared competence that means that
the
union intervenes there where certain
aspects have
a broader context have a transporter
context
and therefore it is important to
intervene
we have to work with member states to
have this stronger
social convergence and in that sense the
letter you referred to was not shocking
for me
it was just reminding about the the
legal
but also the rather
concrete political situation we have in
europe
and i at least personally would not like
to change
yes some examples of the social
convergence that you speak of
in action could be could it not the
european child guarantee with its
minimal provisions
for children on things like housing
education and health care
it could be a whole range of up and
re-skilling activities
for the new work age we're in or it
could be the european globalization fund
providing assistance for workers
displaced due to restructuring
because of globalization there are many
examples when we talk about
economic policy when we are talking
about fiscal policy
this might have consequences for
investment
in social infrastructure in fields like
health policy
education and so on it is very important
always
to have a good assessment of the social
impact of our decisions because
these decisions at the end impact
people's personal lives thank you very
much
well listening to all of this is panatis
chatzi mikhail
you're a board member of the european
youth forum you're from cyprus and you
have particular experience in
inclusivity and education panagiotis
what are your organizations
fears hopes and demands for young people
as labour markets open up again across
europe
one of the fears we have is seeing
history repeat itself many young people
like me still remember the previous
financial crisis
and how youth ended up paying a high
price
in many ways the reason why young people
are being so affected by kovi 19 crisis
is because over the past 10 years or so
our rights have haven't been as should
at the center of policy making
we saw a race to the bottom in terms of
labor legislation
leading us into precarity and vicious
cycles of temporary contract
we normalize low quality or even unpaid
internships as key stepping stones
to enter labour market without realizing
that we were
damaging young people's futures
prospects and change and chances to
become independent
so the fear is that we will see the same
soft uh sort of approaches to youth
now as he was done before on the sake of
stimulating employment in the short run
thanks very much panagiotis a clear case
there
now is your chance to put a point or a
question or both
to commissioner schmidt directly one of
the thing
that this pandemic showed us is how
struggles in the areas of employment and
education and mental health
are interconnected and mutually
reinforcing
how does the european commission plan to
address the mental health impact
of this crisis particularly in the
framework of employment
uh policies well commissioner you were
nodding your head a lot there
what's your response to that point and
to other issues paniotis has raised
i fully agree with the comments which
have been made
but i have to say that lessons have been
learned from the previous crisis
the reaction was not the same as after
the
financial crisis especially in
certain southern countries where finally
the young generations were in a way
sacrificed to the different economic
and and financial measures this time
it's quite different we developed a very
huge
program to invest into jobs into
education
into all kinds of support into
transformation
also of our economy so that's the big
difference
nevertheless i understand that there is
a lot of anxiety and concern
among the young generation it's become a
bit of a cliche would you agree that the
young generation that you speak of is
now being labeled as
the lost generation i do not want to
hear
about the new lost generation i do not
want
a new desperate generation because of
what you described also the
psychological impact
on the young so i think first the labor
market is
key but education is key we cannot
recover the time which might have been
lost
due to the pandemic but we have to make
sure that
the young who have suffered a lot from
the pandemic especially also in their
educational path can recover as
as well as possible this time the second
one
is on the labor market of the post
pandemic
it cannot be the prospect of the young
to be told well
accept any job even if it's for a few
days
even if there is no security going with
it
even if there is no social protection
going with it just
take it because there's no other way i
think this is not an approach
so what commissioner is the way out of a
system that has young people locked in a
stranglehold evidently powerless to
change the status quo i look at that
with some optimism
because in portugal conclusion there is
a very strong commitment
for the young there is clearly said that
the young hour
priority because they are not just our
future
they are also our present and therefore
i think now we have to align our
policies
to the commitments that were taken and
here labor market policies are key
and we have to bring in a bit more
security
in young people's life precariousness is
not a perspective which we can accept
and i could imagine that at one stage in
a quite near future
we sit together social partners business
young people governments those who are
responsible for labor market policies
and we see how can we change this how
can we commit
to a different approach commissioner
schmidt and panagiotis we're heading
south now to the mediterranean
and the italian paradise island of
sardinia well somebody's got to go
and that lucky somebody is you stephen
where i gather you've been posing the
question
paradise what paradise yes paul the
challenge of youth unemployment and all
the social problems associated with it
are especially acute in peripheral areas
of the european union
like this one here for most of the year
the goats and sheep outnumber the people
at least until the tourist season
reaches its crescendo as it is now
work here is usually seasonal precarious
poorly paid
and as the italians say inero the black
economy
untaxed and unregulated in communities
like this one the church is the glue
keeping lives and livelihoods together
so it seemed the right place for me to
find out more about the situation here
alessandro i'm alessandra
in the north west of sardinia i'm 44
years old and i have been a parish
priest
for five years in this place the
greatest difficulty in this region in
particular but in all the coastal areas
of sardinia
is their dependence on tourism which
presents a big problem because people
only work four months of the year and
the rest of the time
they have nothing to do the regional and
municipal authorities to serve criticism
here
because instead of proposing other
activities such as studying or cultural
activities of this kind
people are left with nothing to do
with the reason for these difficulties
can be found in various social
situations such as the ever
increasing number of separations and
divorces
social poverty and above all the huge
difficulties that are
always caused by families but also what
i call
the easy ways out in which they make
money
with less effort and here we're talking
about
mafia drugs and delinquency
[Music]
so how are the social consequences of
the economic precarity many people are
living through here playing out
and what solutions at hand
most young people today do not even want
to study but
they are people who are 30 years old 40
years old
who have degrees but do not have work
they want to create businesses and they
go to present them to the municipality
or the region but they take years to be
approved
what then happens makes sense the young
person in question
for the part becomes depressed and
abandons the project
here in italy there is a lot of
bureaucracy and this
i think is caused by the lack of
commitment on the part of those with
responsibility in this area
there is a lot of demotivation and
subsequently a lot of depression due to
this way of working
instead what should happen and what
could happen
is that the regional authorities in
sardinia should think of tourism as an
annual economy and should offer services
all year round for tourists because
sardinia can offer tourism all year
round
as for italy sardinia's share of the
750 billion euro next generation eu
funding instruments what are your
feelings about how that can best be
deployed
there is insufficient information i know
that they are huge opportunities that
europe provides economically
but little information as if europe
wants to hide what it wants to give
and then the money where is it going
so there is not even good information
about the money that is available
thanks don alessandro challenges abound
at regional national and european level
and if young people are asking what
difference europe is making to their
lives it's possibly as much a rhetorical
question is one to which they're looking
for an answer
but perhaps commissioner schmidt has
some answers we have seen
that the impact of the crisis
of the economic crisis as a consequence
of the pandemic
is very different from one region
to another and talking about sardinia
this island has been impacted a lot
because it
is mainly a tourist destination this
is something which needed european
solidarity because uh
without european solidarity we would
have some kind of dislocation
of europe thank you commissioner for
that uh this is where as we draw to a
close
paul and i invite you to answer on
issues you'd probably like to spend
longer on but there isn't time so please
shoot from the hip
your fellow luxembourg jean-claude
juncker called the commission he led
between 2014 and 2019 the last chance
commission
two years on from that has the last
chance saloon closed for a new social
europe
well i think talking about the last
chance is always
well a formula but it's not the reality
and i think we we seized a new chance
so i do not agree what's a well-chosen
word of advice to young people
i think it's more an encouragement than
an advice
i want to tell them we want to build
back
better together with you that's what we
have to do
this is a commitment it's not just an
advice it's a commitment
if you could pass a directive tomorrow
at european level
what would schmidt's directive be it's
very obvious after the discussion
we had and also after listening our
friend from cyprus
uh giving the young generations
again the feeling of security
fighting precariousness and giving each
one of them
good opportunities in their job but also
in the way they can organize their life
thank you very much commissioner schmidt
paul thanks a lot stephen we'll turn now
to the conference on the future
of europe in particular the preliminary
public consultation currently underway
on what it should be and how in order to
stay relevant
the eu should change let's hear from two
people with their own perspectives
michel barnier former eu brexit
negotiator but first to you panayotis
what's your take
this conference is an opportunity to
push for the changes we want to see
but also to strengthen the enthusiasm
for the current and new generations of
young people
for the european project but to achieve
this the conference must be
an ambitious process and young people to
be
meaningfully included as well be the
ones who will bear the consequences of
the decisions made at this conference in
the future
and here's michelle barnier's take i
caught up with him in central france
recently
promoting his book on the inside track
of the brexit negotiations
what does he want and expect from this
process
i find very important in the serious
moment in which we are
after the brexit and especially after
the covet crisis which created
many of suffering a lot of damage from
illness to death
also and loneliness for me the question
arises there is a lot of concern a lot
of
risk in our societies and all of this
can backfire in europe as we have seen
it was brexit
so i find it very important that we take
the time for a public debate
and an invitation to all citizens to
express themselves
on what we are doing together what we
must do together
so they are on the major issues of
european sovereignty on digital autonomy
on peace and democracy and values there
are a lot of questions that arise
and where is the right level to act do
we have to play at the national
regional level or do we have to act at
the common level together
mr barnier in view of the populist trend
in europe at the moment do you believe
this process can change anything
can it influence the views of people
there is a lot of social anger there's a
lot of worry
it is not the meaning of this
consultation to say everything that we
have done is great and we will continue
and you must understand
no we have to listen to the citizens and
by listening to them we will see that
there are misunderstandings expectations
in particular for europe to give itself
the means of collective actions in the
field of industry the protection of
frontiers
there's naivety in the field of commerce
and culture
young people erasmus at the heart of the
european project
so it's a matter of making it work both
ways of course
at the top we have to say what we do why
we do it how we do it
and from the bottom of the critics and
listening and listening to the citizens
i think it's
very important michelle barnier there
a quick reminder to listeners before we
come to you commissioner schmidt
that you can join this process
yourselves online just go to
futureyou.europa.eu
that's future f-u-t-u-r-e-u dot
europa.eu
then pick your language and decide
whether you want to follow an event
hold an event or just leave an idea
under a range of topics
okay so commissioner you've heard those
clips and there's plenty there to add no
doubt from your side
we have heard a lot of criticism
uh addressed to europe uh in a quite
unjustified way uh i think
finally uh thanks to the european union
we were able to
you